el presidente chileno Gabriel boriccio
enviaba un abrazo fraterno a Gioconda
Ramírez Sofía y Carlos y a todas
aquellas personas a las que Daniel
Ortega ha tratado de despojar de su
nacionalidad nicaragüense no sabe el
dictador que la patria se lleva en el
corazón y en los actos y no se depriva
vía decreto manifestó boric quien se
refería en concreto a los escritores
Gioconda Billy y Sergio Ramírez al
activista feminista Sofía Montenegro y
al periodista Carlos Fernando Chamorro
barrios cuatro de las 94 personas a las
que Ortega ha despojado de su
nacionalidad nicaragüense boric se
convierte así en el primer gobierno
izquierdista latinoamericano en condenar
sin ambigüedades estos hechos y se suma
a lo expresado por la canciller chilena
Antonio urrejola el jueves en la que
manifestó que en las últimas semanas los
hechos han demostrado que se trata cada
día más de una dictadura totalitaria en
la que se persigue cualquier tipo de
disidencia orejola calificó como de suma
gravedad el hecho de que se trate de
despojar la nacionalidad a estas 94
personas y afirmó que el gobierno de
chile Va a continuar denunciando estos
hechos y trabajando para situarse al
lado apoyando a los perseguidos al mismo
tiempo que solicitó que la comunidad
internacional se manifieste y actúe a la
altura de lo que está ocurriendo en el
país centroamericano